A
NOW BATTLES THIS RECESSION,
STAGFLATION AND PROBABLY WORSE
AS WE BATTLE SPIKING GAS PRICES,
ENERGY PRICES, HE SAID TO GIVE
ONE MAJOR ADDRESS ABOUT THE
ECONOMY?
WRONG.
JANUARY 6.
HERE WITH REACTION FORMER
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
REINCE PRIEBUS ALONG WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THE UPCOMING BOOK COME
ON MAN THE TRUTH ABOUT
JOE BIDEN'S TERRIBLE, HORRIBLE,
NO GOOD, VERY BAD PRESIDENCY,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JOE CONCHA.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT JANUARY 6,
THAT'S ALL THEY GOT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR IN LIGHT
OF SECRET SERVICE AGENTS
QUESTIONING THE STAR WITNESS ON
FACTS TO HEAR FROM THEM.
I DON'T THINK IT'S UNFAIR TO
BRING IN HANDWRITING EXPERTS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S UNFAIR TO SEE
IF ANYBODY WAS TOLD TO LIFT
PEOPLE INTO THE RALLY ON JANUARA
METAL DETECTOR, THOSE ARE THINGS
WE COULD FIND OUT IN A DAY OR
TWO AGO, ISN'T IT?
>> 100%, THE DECK WAS STACKED
EARLY ON AS WE ALL KNOW WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS WERE KICKED OFF THE
COMMITTEE BY NANCY PELOSI.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING FOR
ANY UNICORN THEY CAN FIND TO
SAVE THEM FROM THE DEBT WHETHER
IT'S JANUARY 6TH OR ABORTION OR
GUNS, THIS IS THE SECRET LIFE OF
JOE BIDEN.
HE IS LIVING AS YOU POINTED OUT,
HE IS LIVING IN A WORLD OF HIS
OWN FANTASIES AND YOU SPELLED IT
OUT.
TALKING ABOUT GAS PRICES --
THAT'S VLADIMIR PUTIN'S FAULT,
FORGET ABOUT ALL THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS THAT YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
A MILLION TIMES, ABORTION --
THEY ARE GOING TO COME AFTER
GAY MARRIAGE NEXT AND THEN ON
INFLATION TODAY HE SAYS THE REST
OF THE WORLD HAS GOT A LOT
WORSE.
A QUICK LITTLE SEARCH ON GOOGLE
WILL TELL YOU THAT OUR NEIGHBORS
IN CANADA AND MEXICO, THERE
INFLATION NUMBER IS LOWER THAN
THE UNITED STATES.
THEY'VE GOT TO CHANGE THE
NARRATIVE, THEY ARE GRABBING AT
ANYTHING THEY CAN FIND BECAUSE
PEOPLE AREN'T HAPPY AND WHEN
YOU'RE NOT HAPPY YOU CAN'T WIN
COLLECTIONS.
>> Sean: IF DEMOCRATS AND THE
NUMBER IS 78%, IF THEY THINK
HE'S DOING A HORRIBLE JOB, CAN
WE INTERPRET THAT THE POLLS AND
PREDICTIONS, SO MANY OF THE WAVE
ELECTION ARE REAL OR IS IT TOO
EARLY?
I'M ONE OF THE SUPERSTITIOUS
TYPE PEOPLE.
UNTIL ALL THOSE VOTES ARE
COUNTED, UNTIL WE HAVE MORE
INTEGRITY IN OUR SYSTEM, I
ALWAYS WORRY UNTIL I HEAR WE CAN
NOW PROJECT.
>> IT GETS LATE EARLY AROUND
HERE, 129 DAYS TO YOUR POINT TO.
A LOT OF THINGS CAN CHANGE,
INFLATION IS NOT GOING AWAY
ANYTIME SOON AND GAS PRICES ARE
GOING TO BE LOWER AT ANY TIME
SOON IN THE BORDER IS NOT GOING
TO BE SECURED AS WE KNOW.
THOSE THREE THINGS TO STAY IN
PLACE AND FENTANYL IS COMING TO
THIS COUNTRY IN RECORD NUMBERS
KILLING A RECORD NUMBER OF
AMERICANS PARTICULARLY YOUNG
ONES AND AMERICANS ARE GOING TO
VOTE WITH THEIR WALLETS AND
THEIR CONSCIENCE.
IN THIS CASE -- THIS DRIVES ME
CRAZY.
IT BEARS REPEATING.
MR. BIDEN SAYS WE HAVE A LOWER
INFLATION RATE THAN OTHER
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD, LET'S
LIST ALL THE COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
A LOWER INFLATION RATES THAN WE
DO.
I KNOW YOU TOUCHED ON IT BEFORE
BUT I'M SORRY, I'M SICK OF THIS
PRESENT REPEATING THIS LIE OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
HERE'S THE REALITY, CHINA,
SAUDI ARABIA, JAPAN,
SWITZERLAND, INDONESIA,
AUSTRALIA, SOUTH KOREA,
SOUTH AFRICA, ITALY, INDIA,
GERMANY, MEXICO, CANADA, ALL
HAVE A LOWER INFLATION RATES
THAN THE U.S.
CHINA'S INFLATION RATE IS FOUR
TIMES LOWER THAN OURS.
THE PRESIDENT KEEPS SAYING WE
ARE RIGHT ON PAR WITH EVERYBODY
ELSE ARE WE HAVE A LOWER
INFLATION RATE, IT'S NOT TRUE
AND IF YOU ARE TUNED TO ABC-NBC,
CBS, CNN, THEY DON'T SAY THOSE
THINGS.
AS FAR AS AMERICANS BEING
DISSATISFIED WITH THE DIRECTION
OF THE COUNTRY, YOU HAVE AN
INFLATION RATE AT ITS HIGHEST
RATE SINCE THE EARLY 80s, GAS
PRICES AT AN ALL-TIME HIGH,
BORDER LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT IN
THE PRESIDENT THAT SEEMS TOO
OLD, TOO SLOW, TOO INCOMPETENT
TO SOLVE ANY OF THESE PROBLEMS,
THAT'S HOW YOU GET HERE.
RESPONSIBILITY LIES WITH OUR
MEDIA WHO ARE SO HELL-BENT TO
GET RID OF DONALD TRUMP, THEY
DIDN'T BOTHER LOOKING AT THE GUY
WHO REPLACED HIM.
HE HAS BEEN BELOW AVERAGE IN
EVERYTHING HE HAS DONE HIS
ENTIRE LIFE AND HIS FILTH
UPWARDS ALL THE WAY TO THE
PRESIDENCY.
THAT'S WHAT THE NEW BOOK --
THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING IS ALL
ABOUT COME OUT IN SEPTEMBER, YOU
CAN PREVIEW IT NOW.
>> Sean: ARE YOU A JUNKIE?
THAT WAS ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO RUN
ON JANUARY 6, ABORTION, THE
SECOND AMENDMENT AND THE
PLAYBOOK OF REPUBLICANS ARE
RACIST, SEXIST, IS THAT GOING TO
WORK?
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK
BECAUSE IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHERE
THESE RACES ARE APT, THERE ARE
NOT MANY RACES IN AMERICA THAT
ARE IN PLAY AND WHERE THEY ARE
IN PLAY, THEY ARE IN
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD DISTRICTS
WHERE 70% OF THE DEMOCRATS --
70% OF THE DEMOCRATS ARE ALSO
SAYING IN THOSE POLLS THAT THE
COUNTRY IS ON THE WRONG TRACK
AND IT'S ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND
THE SECRET LIFE OF JOE BIDEN IS
NOT GOING TO CONVINCE A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LESS MONEY IN
THEIR BANK, MORE MONEY IN THEIR
GAS TANK, TUITION ISN'T GETTING
ANY LOWER THAT SOMEHOW OR
ANOTHER LIFE IS PRETTY GOOD.
IT'S NOT GOING WELL FOR
JOE BIDEN AND PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT'S.